(electronic music)
- Hi, honey!
Ugly, God.
DC.
Should be called
Desperate Clams.
That's what DC is.
I mean, not a hot
one in the bunch.
You gotta go all the way to
Annapolis to find any puss.
- [Protestors] Hey, hey, ho, ho.
Donald Trump has got to go.
Hey, hey, ho, ho!
- This is way too much
traffic, way more than normal.
These people wandering
around, yelling,
"No tax, tax this, tax that."
I thought we already did this?
What's everyone still
complaining about?
- [Donald] So many hippies.
Hey!
Excuse me, you old
hippie, you're wrong.
You're totally wrong, and
you're totally self-involved.
This is perfect.
Stop the car.
- Unbelievable.
Look at these guys.
Where's your husbands,
where's your husbands?
You shouldn't be free.
It's the weekend,
it's laundry time.
It's laundry time.
(protestors chanting)
- Knock off the
secrecy, Mr. President,
and publicly release
your own tax return.
- [All] Knock it
off, knock it off.
- You don't know what
I'm gonna release,
but it's gonna be a full
release when I do it.
Haven't you ever been
to a massage parlor?
- We are here to say today,
show us the damn tax returns.
(audience cheering)
- What a wonderful little girl.
You wanna take a
picture with me?
- Let's just do it and
then be done, okay?
- We are fed up, we're
fed up with billionaires
bragging that they pay
next to nothing in taxes.
(audience cheering)
Well today, across the country,
Americans are calling bullshit.
(audience cheering)
- [Donald] Typical
self-involved protestor.
I don't like them.
We need to get rid
of these people.
- Next, I have the
honor of introducing
a warrior progressive
who fights daily
for an America where
we have an equal say.
An advocate on the
front line in Congress
to stop Trump's
dangerous agenda.
- Excuse me.
Hey!
Excuse me!
You idiot.
I'm here everybody.
(crowd roars)
Thank you so much.
So many wonderful people.
Such a large crowd.
And it's so great.
It's so great.
And so many of you support me.
And you're here to see me.
And I'm so pleased.
(crowd boos)
Is the wind dying down now?
What's the big deal about
releasing my tax returns?
First off, I claimed
Ivanka as three dependents.
My daughter, my
mother, and my wife.
So what.
I owe 50 million dollars
to Deutsche Bank.
Who cares?
That's publicly known.
But what you don't
know is I know where
all the Nazi gold is hidden.
(inaudible)
I have it.
Just because I have
dirty ties to Azerbaijan,
I have so many ties Azerbaijan.
I have ties to Russia.
But what you don't
know in my tax returns
is I have the original, uncut,
David Hasselhoff video
of him eating a burger
off the floor.
Remember that?
So if we want to
release the tax returns,
we can do it.
Boys, let's get the taxes.
Where are they?
Aren't you glad I'm not
in Mar a Lago today?
So we have these taxes,
and we're going to release them.
And I want you to know
that everyone can
look at them now.
And we're all equal, right?
So let's release them boys!
Release the taxes.
There we go.
Releasing the taxes.
I told Jerry to shred my taxes,
but I thought 'shred'
was Yiddish for collate.
We're going to make
America great again, folks.
Thank you so much!
- [Crowd] Lock him up!
Lock him up!
(bombastic symphonic music)